[Music]
and Grand Theft Auto news it's a bit of
I love ya mrs. Chan teenage police cadet
stole three LAPD cars and patrolled Los
Angeles possibly for weeks before
getting so they stole the cars for good
for possibly weeks not for good for good
as in like they wanted to patrol the
street
I think big is all about knowledge there
were cops I think so so right now
they're investigating whether or not
they were posing as like police officers
and actually pulling people over and
stuff so they're investigating that so
we don't know that yet how do they not
find the [ __ ] car we don't got a
LoJack call question yeah mr. [ __ ]
inventory like whoa we got these many
cars gone that's how they ended up
finding out I'd sooner like how okay
we're missing a car there were two boys
and a girl ages 15 16 and 17
oh my god yeah they're part of like you
know like really young police officers
China like open it yeah the young cadets
were there great white almost hard to
make it these kids involved in this I
don't know but yeah it's like 18
volunteers where they learn about the
criminal justice system and then they go
through like this Academy there was you
three three teenagers right and so
they're saying that they gained the
system by using a vacationing sergeants
name to sign out son guns and radios and
the quality they drove the cars right
out of the station health parking lot
and that's [ __ ] bold what was their
goal now I'm pretty sure they're never
going to be cops ever again yeah finite
Dean really good usually in the cadet
program to become a cop yeah okay but
then if you do this you probably kissing
your top you go goodbye
how did you kids even get involved
that's [ __ ] crazy because usually the
people that I know that want to be
officers at an early age they do join
these programs like the cadet program or
whatever and a lot of them are like
super straight-and-narrow types are they
like those really serious JROTC kids yes
similar to those guys yet what is the
benefit of being in Gerald J Roddick I
think it helps you get into college it's
just like another additional
extracurricular activity to write down
so when I finally discover that there
was the patrol cars missing was when
they were doing inventory they're like
wait there's one missing
he said one and then that's when um even
though there's three empty spaces feel
like - there's one at least like how did
they not figure out the other two so
that's when there was a police officer
that he was running on the street and
then he saw these two cop cars driving
together and like racing and then so
that's when that one police officer was
trying to pull them over and then that
led to a speed chase oh [ __ ] this kids
are crazy they went and pulled over pull
it off hook yep so then um finally it
ended when they both crashed oh my god
those cars are fast - yeah a drop
Corvette motors or supercharged Mustang
motors it was awesome are those Crown
Vic won the crown vics they have the
supercharged Mustang and then the Chevy
Caprice is have the Corvette motors in
holy crap yeah and so after those two
cars crashed they ended up questioning
them and then they discovered there was
a third car involved and they also
discovered on surveillance footage that
there was a girl pumping gas at a gas
station
oh yeah so then one of the two kids that
ended up getting caught he'd say let him
know where the third one was so we found
it Oh snitch
that'd be funny if they checked out more
than cars like for the k-9 dollars a
messy job stay at the station because
there maybe maybe they went to the
freakin the police dog shelter was
checked out for the dogs and they did
say that one of the teams that was
arrested he was wearing a bulletproof
vest
[ __ ] harnesses crazy my god what the
[ __ ] that's some [ __ ] charged with a
lot of [ __ ]
I can't believe what happened in LA -
you know in LA I feel like the cops on
you just came out and started beating
the [ __ ] out of them broad daylight and
it's crazy given those two separate
crashes there was a stir
person involved like an innocent
bystander in her cars you also got
involved in the crash I wonder how the
conversation came down is like you know
be a cool senior prank just like if we
if we get the cars and we pull over all
of our friends like what the [ __ ] what
was going through their mind no I want
to know that they got some guns yeah
they're smart to use a vacationing
sergeant a texture it out I think the
FBI or CIA shoes copies kids yeah you're
thinking next level they could do adults
and they're not scared yeah that's next
level thinking I thought I was a
renegade [ __ ] doing graffiti on a
freeway at 15 you guys are next level
they I look up to them I never I never
infiltrated and pretended like I wanted
I was genuinely interested in being an
officer but I really just wanted a
police car like what if that was their
[ __ ] they infiltrated they made a pact
they're like all right guys pinky swear
high school seniors let's do it must be
really dumb that could be the other
thing because I've known this guy named
James at Riverside he was dumbest Luke
but he was so stupid like it was amazing
how much he could steal things because
he was so dumb he would steal things out
of stores as if it was already here
wow that's how you get away with this
honest way though I've seen him steal
liquor but somebody told me that he
stole a [ __ ] surfboard once Wow
dancing big beverages he's just walked
my towers and it look so convincing that
it would look like it was his that's
when I when I would steal that's what I
would do you are such a piece of [ __ ] I
was oh I mean I think so anything big or
just like [ __ ] oh my god you are one of
those Oh so the key is to walk out
confidently I guess my father kind of
learned when I saw him I think you like
beer and [ __ ] or whatever he would just
walk if you go go walk like position is
you start doing this thing I thought it
is a lot of question to him like he
doesn't look suspicious at all I saw I'm
still [ __ ] a whole bunch of hot
pockets wait wait so my question is why
didn't you saw him do teasing why didn't
you stop her it's like [ __ ] hot it's
hot pockets like not you're not stealing
anything crazy like remember wait you
it's hot pockets it would cause a bigger
scene if anything else so for him he
just took hot pot on my eye you know
that's actually a good question because
I never even thought of stopping my
friends from stealing I always just
thought oh you're gonna get that I want
something too that's the first thing
that came to my mind like mind you if
the do with like taking like cash out of
a register that'd be a different
situation going to stop them ha ha
and that my selfishness whatever your
homies are doing is yeah you don't want
to be a mom like if they stole out of
the cash register then like let's say
the cash register guys start arresting
my friend I gone into a photo op I jump
- cash register guy and then I will grab
even one of the money we both run out I
don't know what it's like now not a
factor homie now be different for me
though because at this point I am I
already attended college and I already
kind of focused on a bucket more on a
solid four yeah this is not high school
is college so Riverside UCR so at this
point I was like what 19 I'll trying to
be a better person so if I saw him take
[ __ ] out of a register I'd be like you
know chill but I think also for me too
when I see a big grocery store I don't
see the the negative effects of it it
was a mom-and-pop store because my
parents owned a business I see the
negative effects it's like hey don't do
that
it's go somewhere else it's great balm I
go to Walmart open yeah so still a
better place my yeah you know I'll go to
the Walmart I remember the first thing
that changed my mind about stealing is
my friend's got chocolate like in
elementary and then they came out and I
was like she didn't pay for that and
then he's like you want some and I'm
like I already like chocolate but he
gave me some other candy and he's like
just because it's stolen doesn't mean it
doesn't taste good and I was like that's
not true it still tastes good that's
just gentle slogic i've ever heard of my
life just kind of stoned on me except I
ain't go change the chemical properties
of the toffee that just changed my mind
I was like what that's true jits bad but
it tastes good so I could still get free
stuff do you think or how do you think
you would handle it like if we right if
your kids would grow up and then you
catch them spilling oh man they're
[ __ ] mommy and [ __ ] their asses up
but then you stole now
fighting every commentator ha ha - what
I figured it I do I [ __ ] made that
[ __ ] up
I know what the hell's wrong with you
I'm [ __ ] your mom and not your [ __ ]
- we knew that what stealing was wrong
it was like we had good parents that
taught us good morals and all that [ __ ]
and it's just I feel like you know
stupid kids are going to do what the
[ __ ] they want to sometimes because they
need to see themselves like if you're
stubborn [ __ ] hit you need to see
yourself like why why it's bad and then
you get cotton ball off of I don't want
my kid to steal man it's so annoying
tell yourself they're gonna steal Ernie
if they do actually love the punch of
mine the fudge done it'd be great oh yes
a certain age you know maybe I'm they're
waving cool yep your babies heal fast
they do the joints they'll loosen [ __ ]
like you can put them in an armoire snap
it and put it right back in its struggle
kidding I feel like you can only hit
kids up to once they learn how to speak
because they don't know how to speak it
so you got to teach them like real quick
don't [ __ ] around I go so you put a baby
[ __ ] that he put him on the table you
just get your finger go like that on the
stomach and then but if they get to like
five or six they start to speak to you
can use logic you don't beat another one
I'm serious yeah just poor late one
water understand what the [ __ ] man I
just think that kids should steal
because that's what the Spartans did
Glengarry cancel I don't get any more
babies and you catch them in any like
and I mean hard school being um and then
your menus just gonna be like daddy but
look at we do you know why cuz I can
look like a little [ __ ] and I had my
own little go game but it wasn't a Gogan
enough that's why so now my kid needs a
go gay so one day my goal is my kids
grow up stronger better crazier than me
and then they kill me and that's when I
feel like I was a great parent hello
everybody
if you liked the video make sure that
you guys leave us a thumbs up because if
not I'm gonna find you where you live
and I'm gonna hug the [ __ ] out of you
with you like you're God other than that
you know there's like more videos up
there for
[Music]